all right let's get started
so
today we're going to talk at some length
about what i mean by this idea of mars
computational
theory level of analysis it's a way of
asking questions about mind and brain
and we're going to talk about that in
the case of color vision
and that's going to take a while we'll
go down and do the demo we'll come back
and talk about color vision and how we
think about it at the level of
computational theory and why that
matters for mind and brain
and then we're going to start in the
second half a whole session on which is
going to roll into next class on the
methods we can use in cognitive
neuroscience to understand the human
brain
and we'll illustrate those with a case
of face perception and we'll talk about
computational theory light very briefly
a face perception what you can learn
from behavioral studies and what you can
learn from functional mri and then we'll
go on and do other methods next time
everybody with the program
all right
so to back up a little
the biggest theme addressed in this
course the big question we're trying to
understand in this field is how does the
brain give rise to the mind okay that's
really what we're in it for that's why
there's lots of cognitive science we're
trying to understand how the mind
emerges from this physical object
and so for the last few lectures you've
been learning some stuff about the
physical basis of the brain what it
actually looks like some of you guys got
to touch it i hope you thought that was
half as awesome as i did
and we got a sense of the basic
physicality of the brain and some of its
major parts
but now the agenda is how are we going
to explain how this physical object
gives rise to something like the mind
and the first problem you encounter is
what is a mind anyway i drew it as a
weird big amorphous cloud because it's
just not obvious how you think about
minds right it feels like one of those
things like could you even have a
science of the mind like what is mine
it's all kind of nervous making right
um and so
our field of cognitive science over the
last few decades has come up with this
framework for how we can think about
minds
and this isn't even a theory it's more
meta than that it's a framework for
thinking about what a mind is
and the framework is the idea that the
mind is a set of computations that
extract representations
okay now that's pretty abstract you can
think of a representation in your mind
as anything from a percept like i see i
see motion right now or i see color
and as you learned before you might see
motion even if there uh isn't actually
motion in the stimulus but that
representation of motion in your head
that percept that's that's a kind of
mental representation
or if you're thinking
you know why is nancy going through this
really basic stuff she's insulting our
intelligence if you know something like
that is going on in the background as
i'm lecturing that's a thought that's a
mental representation of a sort or if
you're thinking oh my god it's after 11
and i'm not going to get to eat until 12
30 i'm going to starve you know whatever
thoughts are going through your head
those are mental representations too
right
and so the question is here how do we
think about those
and so this idea that mental
mental processes our computations and
mental contents are representations
implies that ideally in the long run if
we really understood minds we'd be able
to write the code to do everything that
minds do right and that code would work
in some sense in the same way
now that's a tall order
mostly we can't do that yet like not
even close a few little cases in
perception kind of sort of maybe but
mostly we can't do that yet but that's
the goal that's the aspiration
and so question is how do we even get
off the ground trying to launch this
enterprise of coming up with an actual
precise computational theory of what
minds do
and the first step to that is by
thinking about what is computed and why
and so that is the crux
of david mar's big idea right the brief
reading assignment that i gave you guys
that from mar and he's talking about how
do we think about minds and brains step
number one what is computed and why so
we're going to focus on that for a bit
here
and let's take vision for example
you start with a world out there
that sends light into your eyes that's
my
icon of a retina that blue thing in the
back the back of your eyes sends an
image onto your eye
and then some magic happens
and then you know what you're looking at
okay so that's what we're trying to
understand
what goes on in there in a sense what is
the code that goes on in here that they
takes this as an input and delivers that
as an output
okay
more specifically we can ask as we did
in the last couple of lectures let's
take the case of visual motion so
suppose you're seeing a display like
this like something in front of you
somebody jumps on a beach like that and
there's visual motion information what
are the kinds of things so that's your
input what are the kinds of outputs you
might get from that
well to understand that we need to know
what is computed and why
so what is computed well lots of things
you might see the presence of motion
you might see the presence of a person
actually you can detect people just from
their pattern of motion if we should
have done this at that demo write me a
note to think about that next time if we
stuck little tiny leds on each of my
joints and we're in a totally black room
and i jumped around and all you could
see was those dots moving you would see
that it was a person it would be
trivially obvious so motion can
give you lots of information aside from
something's moving and what direction is
it moving
you can see someone's jumping that also
comes from the information about motion
you can infer something about the health
of this person or even their mood so
there's a huge range of kinds of
information we glean from even a pretty
simple stimulus attribute like motion
and so we're going to understand how do
we perceive motion we first need to get
organized about what's the input and
which of those outputs are we talking
about and probably the code that goes on
in between in your head
or in a computer program if you ever
figured out how to do that will be quite
different for each of those things but
that's the way you need to be thinking
about
mines okay what are the inputs what are
the outputs and then as soon as you pose
that challenge like okay let's say it's
just moving dots and you're trying to
tell if that's a person think about what
is the code you'd write just these
moving dots
how the hell are you going to go from
that
to detecting if those dots are on the
joints of a person who's moving around
versus on something else that's how you
think what are the computational
challenges involved okay
and i'm not going to ever ask you guys
to write that code we're just
going to consider it as a thought
enterprise to kind of see what the
problem is that the brain is facing that
it's solving
okay and so mars big idea is this whole
business of thinking about what is
computed and why what the inputs and
outputs are and what the computational
challenges are getting from those inputs
to those outputs that all of that is a
prerequisite for thinking about minds or
brains okay we can't understand what
brains are doing until we first think
about this that's why i'm carrying on
about this at some length
and mar writes so beautifully that i'm
just going to read some of my favorite
paragraphs because um paraphrasing
beautiful prose is a sin so mars says
trying to understand perception by
studying only neurons is like trying to
understand bird flight by studying only
feathers it just can't be done
to understand bird flight you need to
understand aerodynamics only then can
one make sense of the structure of
feathers and the shape of wings
similarly you can't reach an
understanding of why neurons in the
visual system behave the way they do
just by studying their anatomy and
physiology
okay you have to understand the problem
that's being solved okay
further he says
the nature of the computations that
underlie perception depends more on the
computational problems that have to be
solved than on the particular hardware
in which their solutions are implemented
so he's basically saying we could have a
theory of any aspect of perception that
would be essentially the same theory
whether you write it in code and put it
in a computer or whether it's being
implemented in a brain yeah
mar was many things he was a he was a
visionary a visionary who studied vision
a truly brilliant guy with a very strong
engineering background and this is you
know now pervading the whole field of
cognitive science that people take an
engineering approach to understanding
minds and brains to try to really
understand how they
work okay
so to better understand this we're going
to now consider the case of color vision
and so in this case we start with color
in the world that sends images onto the
back of your retina some magic happens
and we get a bunch of information out
so the question we're going to consider
is what do we use color for
okay and we're going to use the same
strategy we used in the edgerton center
of trying to understand some of the
things that that we use color for
by experiencing perception without color
okay what are the outputs okay so to do
that we're going to head over right now
to the imaging center and we're going to
have a cool demo by rosalesa
so
if it's going to be faster to leave your
stuff here i don't know maybe we should
yeah
yeah we'll lock the room okay um yeah
how long are we going to be today
10 minutes something like that and i
need everyone to boogie because there's
a lot of stuff i want to get through
today so let's
go
all right so what do we use color for
when we have it
it's not a trick question supposed to be
really obvious now
yeah what's your name
chardon hi
uh do you think it was booty
yeah
yeah choosing which
what else related to that but different
yeah
yeah yeah like what what did you notice
that you could identify better
but besides identifying and choosing
what else much more generally bringing
things into our awareness like with the
reds in particular the strawberries yeah
like do you find them easier to find no
much harder
oh yeah right harder without the light
exactly what else
yeah like driving like you need to have
color to know the traffic lights totally
totally that's a modern invention but a
really important one
what else
are we in general
are we very general or like whatever
what do we use color for i mean we use
it to like figure out
like what's what to eat because it's
like one of the strawberries isn't
actually a strawberry
so yeah i use color too
uh-huh and the bananas did anybody
notice sometimes it's hard to tell yeah
point in the bag
say more
totally did you feel like people's faces
looked a little sickly
absolutely
absolutely okay so this is just to show
you that a lot of a lot of
computational theory starts with sort of
common sense of just reasoning what do
we use this stuff for it helps to not
have it just to reveal what we use it
for but you guys have just reinvented
the the key insights and early field of
color vision
okay so standard story is to find fruit
like if you ask yourself how many
berries are here take a moment get a
mental tally
how many berries okay ready now how many
berries okay you see more
and in fact there's a long literature
showing that um primates who have uh
three cone colors we're not going to go
through all the physiological basis of
cones and stuff like that but they have
richer color vision
because the number of different color
receptors in their retina
they're better at finding berries and in
fact a paper came out a couple years ago
where they studied wild macaques on an
island off of puerto rico called cayo
santiago and the macaques there have a
natural variation genetically where some
of them have two photo two color
photoreceptors instead of three okay and
in fact they followed them around and
the monkeys that have three
photoreceptors types are better at
finding fruit than the ones that have
only two okay so that story that's just
been a story for a long time turns out
it's true
and also as you guys have already said
to not just find things but identify
properties like you can probably tell
whether you'd want to eat those bananas
on the bottom maybe not it's hard to
tell on the top which ones you'd like
and yet that's all you need to know okay
so these are just a few of the ways that
we use color and why it's important
but there is a very big problem now that
we try to think figure out okay what is
the code that goes between the
wavelength of light hitting your retina
and trying to figure out what color is
that thing so here's the problem
we want to determine a property of the
object of its surface properties its
color right that's a material property
of that thing
but all we have so here's a thing we'll
call that reflectance it's a property of
wavelength but you can think of it as
for now just a single number it's a
property of that surface
but all we have
is the light coming from that object to
our eyes that's called luminance i'm not
going to test you in these particular
words but you should get the idea okay
so that's what we have that's our input
but here's the problem
the light that's coming off the object
is a function not just of the object but
of the nature of the light that's
shining on the object that's called the
illuminate
so the problem is
we have this equation this light coming
from the object to our eyes is the
product of the properties of the surface
and the incident light
okay
and our problem is we have to solve for
l
i'm sorry we have to solve for r the
property of the object given l what is r
that's a problem
okay
that's kind of like if i said a times b
is 48 please solve for a and b
okay
that's known in the field as an
ill-posed or underdetermined problem we
don't have enough information to
uniquely solve this
okay that's a very very deep problem in
perception and a lot of cognition we are
often in fact most of the time in this
boat
okay
so the implications are when we want to
infer reflectance of the property of the
object from l
we must bring in other information
right we must be able to make we must
have some way to make guesses about i
about the light shining on that object
okay
so the big point is many many inferences
in perception and cognition are
ill-posed in exactly this way
all right
and so here are two other examples of
ill-posed problems in perception
in shape perception
you have a similar situation you have
stuff in the world that's making an
image on the on the back of your eyes
okay that's optics
what we're trying to do as perceivers is
reason backwards from that image what
object in the world caused that image on
my retina that's sometimes called
inverse optics because you're trying to
reason the opposite way that's basically
what we're doing in vision
so here's a problem
like it's a crappy diagram but if you
can see here there's three very
different
surface shapes here
that are all casting the same image for
example on a retina
you could do this with cardboard and
cast it with a shadow does everybody get
what this shows here what that means is
if you start with this and you have to
reason backwards to the shape that
caused it
that's an ill-posed problem big time it
could be any of those things this
information doesn't constrain it does
everybody see that problem
okay
so that's another ill-posed problem
here's a totally different example of an
ill pose problem that's that's big in
cognition when you when you learn the
meaning of a word especially as an
infant trying to learn language
the classic example the philosophers
like god knows why philosophers like
weird stuff but never mind um
somebody points to that and says gav a
guy
and your job is to figure out what does
gavagai mean
okay so gavagai could mean all kinds of
different things
it could just mean rabbit if you already
have a concept of a rabbit
it could mean fur
it could mean ears
it could mean motion if the rabbit is
jumping around
or in the example the philosopher's love
it could mean undetached rabbit parts
weird but anyway philosophers like that
kind of thing anyway the point is it's
ill-posed we don't know from this what
is the correct meaning of the word does
everybody see how this
underdetermines
the correct meaning of the word we don't
have enough information to solve it
okay
so um
yeah
so there's a there's a whole literature
on the extra assumptions that infants
bring to bear to constrain that problem
so they can make a damn good guess about
what the actual meaning of the word is
okay the whole big literature quite
fascinating
okay but for now i just want you to
understand what an ill-posed problem is
and why it's central to understanding
perception and cognition
okay so back to
the case of color
as i said the big point is that lots of
inferences including
determining the reflectance of an object
are imposed and so we have to bring in
assumptions and knowledge
from other places from our knowledge of
the statistics and the physics of the
world our knowledge of particular
objects all kinds of other things must
be brought to bear
okay
so all of that again is considering the
problem of color vision at the level of
mars computational theory notice we
haven't made any measurements yet we've
just thought about light and optics and
what the problem is and what we use it
for okay
all this stuff you know what what is
extracted and why are the reflectance of
an object useful for characterizing
objects and finding them
what cues are available only l
and that's a problem
uh because it's ill-posed
okay
next question
so obviously we get around and we can we
can figure out what colors are which
what are the other sources of
information that we might use in
principle and that humans do use in
practice
okay
um
and so all of that kind of stuff has
been done without making any
measurements we're just thinking about
the problem itself
okay
all right
um
so next uh mars other levels of analysis
algorithm and representation and
hardware are more standard ones you will
have encountered which is why i'm making
a big deal of computational theory it's
really his major
novel
contribution but it's better understood
by contrast with these so at the level
of algorithm and representation this is
like what is the code that you would
write to solve that problem right
and so we could ask how does the system
do what it does
can we write the code to do it and what
assumptions and computations
and representations would be entailed
so how would we find out how humans do
this
well one of the ways is a slightly more
organized version of what you guys just
did
and that's called psychophysics
psychophysics just means showing people
stuff and asking them what they see or
playing them sounds and asking them what
they hear
you can do it in very sophisticated
formalized ways or you can do it like we
just did talk to us about what the world
looks like okay usually psychophysics
means a slightly more organized version
okay so here's an example
in fact it's a cool demo also from rosa
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to show you a bunch of pictures of cars
and your task is going to be to shout
out loud as fast as you can the color of
the car
okay they're going to appear on the
screen everyone ready
as fast as you can shout it out loud
here we go what color
okay interesting okay here's another one
uh-huh interesting ready here we go
here's another one
okay here's another one ah you guys
caught on to that pretty fast okay
so um good job
um nice consensus although i noticed a
little bit of transition there which is
very interesting
um but here's the thing
all of those cars are the exact same
color
the body of the car is the exact same in
all of them and if you don't believe it
here's i'm going to occlude everything
except for a patch okay here we go
boom they're all gray
i know it's awesome
it's rosa that's awesome not me i just
had to bum this because it's so awesome
okay so rosa spent months designing
these stimuli to make a particular test
particular ideas about vision
but the basic demo is simple and
straightforward you can get the point
here
okay
so what's going on here
what's going on here is that you guys
the algorithm running in your head
that's trying to figure out what is the
color of that car is trying to solve the
ill-posed problem
and it's using other information than
just the luminance of light coming from
the object it's using information from
the rest of the object it's making
inferences about l the luminance the
light hitting the object okay and in
particular when you look at that picture
up there what is the color of light
shining on that car
yeah
right officially known as teal in the
field but some of you shouted out green
first because that's what you saw first
is the color of light okay what's the
color of light hitting that car
yeah purple magenta here
yeah and over there
yeah yellow orange yeah
okay so basically what your visual
system did is look quickly figure out
the color of the incident light l
and use that to solve the otherwise ill
pose problem of solving for r the color
of the car
and in this case this demo shows that if
you just change the color of the
illuminant light and hold constant the
actual wavelengths coming from that
patch you can radically change the
perceived color of the car everyone got
that
okay
yeah if i ran this to a computer yeah
asked to get the
the intensity of the pixel at like on
the hood of the car there it would it
would not correspond to yellow across
one degree
uh well it depends what you're asking
the computer exactly if you hold up a
spectrophotometer that's just going to
measure the wavelength of light they're
all gray
right there on top of those cars they're
all the exact same neutral gray
that's just the raw physical light
coming from that patch
okay
but if you coded up the computer to do
something smart
and you coded it up to take other cues
from the image try to figure out what l
is and therefore solve for r you might
be able to get it to do the right thing
i just mean
just like you look at the pixels like in
the matrix
like
the color on the car would it be what
yellow is
great they're all great so that's what
that's what i was trying to show you
here is that in fact they are actually
gray
right that's the cars are underneath
there and you can see they're all
exactly the same and they're gray and
there's no color in it
okay everyone got that
all right
okay
so all of that is a little baby example
of
psychophysics what we do at the level of
trying to understand the algorithms and
representations extracted by the mind to
try to figure out
what are these strategies that we use to
to solve problems about the visual world
okay and so behavior or psychophysics or
seeing as you just did
can reveal those assumptions and reveal
some of the tricks that we're using
in the human visual system to solve
those ill-posed problems okay so in this
case it was assumptions about
the illuminant that enabled us to infer
the reflectance from the luminance
okay
the third level mar talks about is the
level of hardware implementation in the
case of brains that's
neurons and brains
and so we won't cover this in any detail
here but there's lots and lots of work
on the brain basis of color vision we'll
mention it briefly next time so this is
some of rose's work showing those little
blue patches on the side of the monkey
brain that are involved in color vision
and some work that rosa did in my lab
showing the bottom surface of the human
brain with a very similar organization
with those little blue patches in there
that are particularly sensitive to color
so you can study brain regions that do
that if it's a monkey you can stick
electrodes in there and record from
individual neurons and see what they
code for and you can really tackle at
multiple levels the hardware hardware
neural basis of color vision and brains
as well
okay
so the big general point is we need lots
of levels of analysis to understand a
problem like color vision okay
and so accordingly we need lots of
methods to understand those things all
right
so what i want to do next is now launch
into this
this whole thing about the different
methods that we can use in the field in
this part of the lecture we'll go on to
next time but let's get going everybody
good with this so far all right
um so we're going to use the case of
face perception to think about
the different kinds of questions and
different levels of analysis and face
perception so let me start by saying why
face perception not just that i've
worked on it for 20 years although i'll
admit that's relevant there's lots of
other good reasons beyond that why we
should care about face perception
so
i don't have a demo that enables me to
kind of put you in a situation where you
can see everything but faces
that would be cool and informative if we
could do that
but failing that i can tell you about
somebody who's in that situation
and this is a guy named jacob
jacob hodes
so this is a picture of him recently i
met him around a decade ago when he was
a freshman at swarthmore
and he sent me an email
and he said
i've just learned about face perception
and the phenomenon of prosopagnosia the
fact that some people have a specific
deficit in face recognition
and it explains everything in my life
and i want to meet you
and i said because he knew i worked on
face perception i said that's awesome i
would love to meet you but i got to tell
you i'm not going to be able to help so
if you're interested in chatting please
please come by
um but
i don't want you to feel like i'm going
to be able to do anything useful he said
no i don't care i just want to i want to
understand the science so he comes by
and by the way one of the one of the
things that people have wondered for a
while is are people who have particular
problems with face recognition are they
just socially weird are they just like
bizarre like maybe a little bit on the
spectrum they don't pay attention to
faces and so they don't get them very
well and so forth
um or can they be like totally normal in
every other respect except for just face
perception and so i was very interested
i'd only emailed with this guy and when
he showed up in my office within about
you know 15 seconds it's like this is
like the nicest normalest kid you could
ever meet such a nice guy so normal
socially adept smart thoughtful lovely
lovely person
so i chatted with him for a long time
and he told me he was then halfway
through he grew up in lynn massachusetts
and he went off to swarthmore his
freshman year
and he had been having a really rough
time of it
because in his hometown he was with the
same group of kids all the way from
first grade through high school
and so in fact he he just can't
recognize faces at all never could when
he was a little kid his mom used to
drive him to the
practice field and they would sit there
and come up with cues about this is how
you tell that's johnny he's got this
weird thing about us here and this is
how you tell that's bobby and they would
like practice and practice
um and so he developed these clues to be
able to figure out who was who in his
small little cohort of kids that he knew
um you know all the way through high
school
then he goes off to college and it's all
these new people
and he's screwed
and he said to me that he was just
devastated because he would go to a
party and he would meet someone and
think wow this is a really nice person
you know they they i would really like
to be this person's friend but he would
realize he would have no way to find
that person again
and so the point he's like you know you
don't want it like it's kind of like
oversharing to say when you've met
somebody for 10 minutes like by the way
i'm not going to be able to find you you
have to find me it's like you just don't
want to have to go there yet right
so there's all kinds of things that
would make it a real drag to not be able
to recognize other faces
and now having said all of that i'll say
that a surprisingly large percent of the
population is in jacob's situation
about two percent of the population it
will be unsurprising if there are one or
two of you in here and if there is you
can tell me later i'd love to scan you
um
but um
uh about two percent of the population
has routinely fails to recognize family
members people they know really well
right
um and so
and interestingly this is completely
uncorrelated with iq
or with any other perceptual ability
your ability to read or recognize scenes
or anything else yeah that's the kind of
thing where you either have it or don't
have it oh good question no it's a it's
a it's a gradation so the two percent of
the bottom are not like this two percent
who are really screwed and everyone else
is up here it's a hugely wide
distribution and the point is that the
bottom end of that distribution is
really really bad like they just can't
do it at all
similarly the top end of that perspec
distribution is
weirdly good
they are so good at face recognition
that they have to hide it socially
because otherwise people feel creeped
out like for example as one of those
people they're called super recognizers
a bunch of them have been hired by um
by investigation
services in in london recently as part
of their kind of crime solving unit
those people are so good that um that
one of them said to me we scanned a few
of these people one of them said
you know if i if i if i you know she
recounted this event where she's um
standing in line waiting for movie
tickets and she realizes that the person
in front of her in line
was sitting at the next table over at a
cafe four years before she says if i
share this information with that person
they'll be creeped out so i've just
learned to keep it to myself but i know
that was the same person right
so there's a huge spread you had a
question a while back
patient um is that so like for example
jacob looking at a person could describe
that absolutely
he knows that it's a face he can tell if
they're male or female he can tell if
they're happy or sad
um it looks like a face to him he just
doesn't look different than anyone else
yeah is there any difference like okay
like for example my father he can tell
faces in person just fine but like when
he watches videos of people he just
cannot like he cannot recognize faces at
all so is there any like difference
there are lots of cues i mean that's a
very interesting exercise to think about
what are the cues that you have in
person
right you have all kinds of other things
first of all there's lots of
constraining information the person
you're looking at there are all kinds of
things you know about where you are and
who that might be
that help right
um
so yeah there's many different cues to
face recognition that might be engaged
here
so my point is just that um face
recognition matters
like you can get by if you can't do it
but it sucks it's really hard okay
okay so mort yes questions
no they see the structure of a face they
see a proper face if the eye was in the
wrong place they would know
they absolutely know the structure of
the face it just looks they all look
kind of the same
by the way there's a we don't have time
to talk about this in any detail but
there's a well-known effect that
probably many of you guys have
experienced which is called the other
race effect
and that is the fact that they all look
the same whoever they are if you have
less experience looking at that group of
people you're less well able to tell
them apart
okay i have this problem teaching all
the time i grew up in a rural lilywhite
community my face recognition is not so
good to begin with and it's really not
good for non-caucasian faces it's
embarrassing as hell it feels
disrespectful i hate it
you know i fault myself but actually
it's just a fact of the perceptual
system your perceptual system is tuned
to the statistics of its input
and um and it's not so plastic later in
life
um and so um a way to simulate
a version that some of you may have
experienced is whatever race of faces
you have less experience with if you
find those people hard to distinguish
it's not that you can't tell it's a face
it's not that you could tell that you
would be able to tell if the nose was in
the wrong place it's just hard to tell
one person from another so it's a lot
like that
i really need to get going so i'll take
one more question and go wait could you
like
kind of use an analogy it's like
being able to tell people apart by like
their hands or something
like to the point that like you just
like you know you can't really tell
people apart by like their hands usually
so is that kind of how people
feel like it's just looking at a body
that's all you had yeah yeah probably
probably yeah and there is by the way an
interesting literature you show people
photographs of their own hand and a
bunch of other hands people can't pick
out their own hand from
so yeah you're right we're not so good
at that
um
okay i'm going to go ahead if you guys
are interested i could post there's some
there's a whole fascinating literature
here but actually i got dinged last year
for talking about face recognition too
much and prosopagnosia we all heard
about in the 900 in 900. so i took most
of that out and now you guys are asking
me so i don't know what the right thing
is but i'm going to go on and i will put
some optional readings online especially
if you send me an email and tell me to
do that okay
so point is faces matter a lot
they matter you know for the quality of
life they're important because they
convey a huge amount of information not
just the identity of the person but also
their age sex mood race direction of
attention so if i'm lecturing like this
right now and i start doing that
you guys are going to wonder what the
hell's going on over there yeah i saw a
few heads turn i'm just doing a little
demo here right we're very attuned to
where other people are looking okay so
there's just one of many different
social cues we get from faces they're
just an incredibly rich bunch of
information in a face
um
we read in aspects of people's
personality from the shape of their face
even though it's been shown with some
interesting recent studies there's
absolutely nothing you can infer about a
person's personality from the shape of
their face we all do it and we do it in
systematic ways
another reason this is important and
faces are some of the most common
stimuli that we see in daily life
starting from infancy where i think
about 40 percent of waking time there's
a face right in front of an infant's
eyes
and probably these abilities to extract
all this information
have been important throughout um our
primate ancestry
so that's just to say there's a big
space of face perception and now we're
going to focus in on just face
recognition telling who that person is
all right
so what questions do we want to answer
about face recognition well a whole
bunch of them
and what methods do we want to use so
let's start with some basic questions
about face recognition
well first as usual we want to know what
is the structure of the problem in face
recognition what are the inputs what are
the outputs why is it hard right just as
we've been doing for motion and color
that's mars computational theory level
we want to know how does face
recognition actually work in humans what
computations go on what representations
are extracted
and is that answer different do we are
we running different code in our heads
when we recognize faces from when we
recognize toasters and apples and dogs
okay
another facet of that do we have a
totally different system for face
recognition from the recognition of all
those other things if so then we might
want different theories of how face
recognition works from our theories of
how object recognition works
how quickly do we detect and recognize
faces that'll help constrain what kinds
of computations might be going on
and of course how was face recognition
actually implemented in neurons and
brains so those are just some of the big
wide open questions we want to answer
so now let's consider
what are our tools for considering these
things and you guys should all know
what tools are available for thinking at
the level of mars computational theory
basically just thinking right you can
collect some images too but basically to
understand this we just think
so for example
um as i keep saying at the level of mars
computational theory we want to know
what is the problem to be solved what is
the input what is the output how might
you go from that input to that output
okay so for example here's a stimulus
that might hit a retina
and then some magic happens and then you
just say julia
okay so we want to know what's going on
in that magic okay and if a different
image hits your retina you go oh brad
that is i wouldn't i'm live in a cave
but i barely get out of the lab but i
understand that these are people most
people recognize that's why i use them
that's a question what goes on here in
the middle
um and your first thought is well duh
easy
we could just make a template a kind of
store the pixels that match that image
and take the incoming image and see if
it exactly matches
and that's going to work great right
no
why not
louder
yeah
yeah absolutely that's not going to work
at all
and the problem is
that we don't just have one picture of
julia that we can match
there are loads of loads of totally
different kinds of pictures of julia all
of which we look at and immediately go
julia no problem
okay
and so
that means what what is it that we're
doing in our heads if we're storing
templates we have to store a lot of them
okay
so
um
all those differences in the images so
we could memorize lots of templates well
that has long been taken as like the
reductio out absurdum like that's the
ridiculous hypothesis how could that be
how could there be room in here to store
lots of templates of each person
um and furthermore how would that work
for people we don't know
the other idea which is very vague right
now
is that well maybe we extract something
that's that's common across all of those
maybe something like the distance
between the eyes something about the
shape of the mouth
of other kinds of properties that might
be invariant across those images that is
that you could come you could pull out
that information from any of those
images okay it's sounding very vague
because it is vague nobody knows what
those would be but the idea is maybe
there's some
image invariant properties of a face you
can get from here that you can then
store and use to recognize faces
okay
so
now we can to think about this we can
step back and say okay how is this done
in machines
so machine face recognition didn't work
well at all until very recently
okay and then all of a sudden a couple
years ago as i said here's another paper
from the different one that i showed you
before this one is vgg face one of the
major deep net systems for face
recognition it's widely used
there was another one the year before
all of this
since 2014 2015 hugely cited widely
influential they're on all your
smartphones boom it all just happened
like nearly overnight okay with with the
availability of lots of images to train
deep nets so now these things are
extremely effective
um and accurate and so in some sense
those networks are possible models of
what we're doing in our heads when we
recognize faces it doesn't mean we do it
in the same way but it's a possibility
it's a hypothesis we could test
okay yeah what is the current state of
the literature surrounding getting other
information from people's faces like
moods lots lots they're like simple you
know there's like conferences and um
machine vision competitions on
extracting you know personality
properties mood properties every
possible thing you can imagine this is
like a huge a lot of people care about a
huge field in computer vision and
there's also a huge field in cognitive
science asking what humans pull from
success
oh god others would know that better
than me i bet it's pretty damn good a
lot of it yeah yeah i mean these things
are suddenly extremely effective
yeah
okay and there will be by the way later
in the course my postdoc katharina dobbs
who knows that literature much better
than i do we'll talk about
deep nets and their application in human
cognitive neuroscience and
she knows a lot about the various
networks that process face information
okay so this is progress now we have
some kind of computational model
trouble is nobody really has a
intuitive understanding of what vggg
face is actually doing like you know how
to train one up there it is but how do
we don't really understand what it's
doing
and further we have no idea if what it's
doing is anything like what humans are
doing
okay
so it's progress that we have a model
now that we didn't have like five years
ago
um but we still have all these questions
open okay so on this first question what
do we want to know what we've discovered
at the level of mar computational theory
is
a if not the central challenge and face
recognition is a huge variation across
images right which you know just by
thinking about it or trying to write the
code
okay
so
um oh i'm just barely able i'm going to
race along and anja's going to tell me
in five minutes to switch okay
um so i want to talk just a little bit
about behavioral data i'll run out of
time and we'll roll this in last time
because i want to include functional mri
because you guys need it for the
assignment okay
so how are we going to figure out what
humans represent about faces
okay so here we are
we consider this possibility that one
way to solve this problem is by
essentially memorizing lots of templates
for each person
another possibility is this kind of
vague and kuwait idea that maybe there's
some abstract representation that'll be
the same across all of those
how are we going to figure out which
humans do
well
if we're really memorizing lots of
templates for each person and that's how
we recognize them in all their different
guises
that wouldn't work for people we didn't
know that is you you wouldn't be able to
take two different photographs of the
same person and know if it's the same
person or not
right
because you could only do this by
memorizing everybody get that idea
whereas whatever this other idea is it
should work somewhat for novel
individuals you don't already know here
are two photographs same person or
different person
so now let's ask
can humans do this
do we store lots of templates for
individuals or can we do something more
abstract
well if we can store if we simply deal
with this problem by storing lots of
templates for each individual maybe not
literally pixel templates but some kind
of literal some kind of snapshot
then the key test is we shouldn't be
able to do this matching task if we
don't know that person everybody get the
logic here
okay so let's try it
so this paper a few years ago jenkins at
all asked that question so here's what
they did
they collected a whole bunch of
photographs of dutch politicians
with multiple images of each politician
okay then they gave them to people on
cards and they said
there are multiple images of each person
and i'm not going to tell you how many
different politicians are in this deck
just sort them in piles so there's a
different pile for each person
okay i'm going to show you a low-tech
version of this i'm going to show you a
whole bunch of pictures all in one array
and you guys are going to try to figure
out how many people are there
okay
everybody ready i'm just going to leave
it up for a few seconds it's going to be
lots of pictures your task is how many
different individuals are depicted here
here we go
okay write down your best guess just
kind of look around
you know
okay everybody got a guess
okay write down your guess
okay
how many people think there are over 10
different individuals there
one okay how many people think over five
yeah
probably half of you
how many people think over three
most of you
they're two
what does that mean that means you can't
do it
that means you can't match different
images of the same person
if you don't know that person
pretty surprising isn't it
we think we're so awesome at face
recognition because most of the time
what we're doing is recognizing people
we know people we've seen in all
different viewpoints and here
arrangements and stuff
if you haven't see if you don't have
lots of opportunity to store all those
things and it's a novel face we're
really bad at that
okay
yeah but there's a constraint of time
yeah yeah i was trying to make the demo
work but you know the way okay so the
way they do this task people have
unlimited time and they're just kind of
sorting them the mean number of piles
that people made in this experiment was
seven and a half
correct answers too
okay
okay now you might say well maybe those
are shitty photographs
right okay so here's the control those
are dutch politicians they then did the
same experiment on dutch people who look
at that photograph and in about two
seconds say two
duh
okay
so if you know there's nothing wrong
with those photographs it's just a
matter of whether you know those people
or not
okay so the point of all of this
is that this crazy story
that
in fact what a lot of what we're doing
i'm sort of simplifying here but a lot
of what we're doing in face recognition
a lot of the way we deal with all this
image variability is not that we have
some very abstract fancy
high-level
um representation of each individual
face we just have lots of experience
with faces and we use that so that if we
have a novel face that we don't have all
that experience with we're not so good
at it i'm going to run out of time so
i'll take one question and go on um how
do they control for you know the issue
you said about like if you don't have
experience with like
certain races yeah
i'm sure whenever you do face
recognition experiments you make sure
that you know if your dominant subject
pool is caucasian you have caucasian
faces or whatever yeah
if unless it's something you don't
understand i'm going to hang around
after class you can ask me questions
there or you have to if you have to go
you can email me because i really want
to get through this next bit okay
okay
so um
okay so there we are with that so what
this suggests kind of sort of is that
whatever we're doing
it's something that benefits enormously
from lots and lots of experience with
that individual maybe it's not literal
memorization of actual pixel-like
snapshots but it's something more like
that than anybody would have guessed
before this experiment
okay
okay
all right i'm gonna skip this awesome
stuff here
okay
um
okay so uh the the the benefits of
actually gonna come back and do that
slide next time too we're gonna cut
straight to
functional mri i'm sorry about this but
i just really want you guys to have this
background in case you don't you
probably do but
um so functional mri another cool method
in cognitive neuroscience and how would
it be useful here okay so first what is
it
functional mri is the same as regular
mri that's in
ten probably tens of thousands of
hospitals around the world
the big advances in functional mri were
when some physicists in the early 90s
figured out how to take those images
really fast and how to make images that
reflect not just the density of tissue
but the activity of neurons at each
point in the brain okay that was big
stuff okay early 1990s and so the reason
it's a big deal it is the best
highest spatial resolution method for
making pictures of human brain function
non-invasively that means without
opening up the head
all right so that's an important thing
that's why there's lots and lots of
papers on it that's why we're going to
spend a lot of time on it
the bare basics are that the functional
mri signal that's used is called the
bold signal that stands for blood
oxygenation level dependent signal
okay what that means is this
basic signal uh is blood flow and so the
way it works is if a bunch of neurons
some place in your brain start firing a
lot that's metabolically expensive to
make all those neural neurons fire
um and so you have to send more blood to
that part of the brain so it's just like
if you go for a run
the muscles in your legs need more blood
delivered to them to supply them
metabolically for that increased
activity and so the blood flow increase
to your leg muscles will increase okay
well similarly the blood flow increases
to active parts of the brain
now the weird part of it is that for
reasons nobody completely understands
the blood flow increase more than
compensates for the oxygen use so the
signal is actually backwards active
parts of the brain
have
less not more deoxygenated hemoglobin
compared to oxygenated hemoglobin
and the relevance of that is that
oxygenated hemoglobin and deoxygenated
hemoglobin are magnetically different in
the way that the mri signal can see
so the basic signal you're looking at is
how much oxygen is there in the blood in
that part of the brain
and hence
how much blood flow went there and hence
how much neural activity was there did
that sort of make sense i'm not going to
test you on which is paramagnetic and
which is diamagnetic i never remember i
couldn't care less but you should know
what the basic signal is right it's a
magnetic difference that results from
oxygenation differences that result from
blood flow differences that result from
neural activity
more oxygenated and because it over
compensates for oxygen for for the
metabolic use of the neurons
the active parts that you see with an
mri signal
have more oxygenated hemoglobin right
okay
all right so that's the basic signal and
because that's the basic signal there's
a bunch of things we can tell already so
first of all
um
i'm just going to am i going to do this
i'm going to skip over this it doesn't
really matter
because it's all based on blood flow one
it's extremely indirect
neural activity blood flow change over
compensation different at magnetic
response mri image
right so you would think with all those
different steps that you would get a
really weird non-linear messy crappy
signal out the other end
and it is one of the major challenges of
my personal atheism
but actually you get a damn good signal
out the other end and it's pretty linear
with neural activity which seems like
kind of a freaking miracle given how
indirect it is okay but that has
empowered this whole huge field to
discover cool things about the
organization of the brain
okay nonetheless are many caveats
because it's blood flow the signal is
limited in spatial resolution down to
people fight about this but around a
millimeter there are cowboys in the
field who think that they can get less
than a millimeter maybe i don't know
it's debated
uh and the temporal resolution is
terrible
blood flow changes take a long time
think about it you start running how
long does it take before the blood flow
increases to your calves well if you're
really fit it's probably fast but still
going to take a few seconds takes about
six seconds for those blood flow changes
in the brain after neural activity
and it happens over a big sloppy chunk
of time and so you cannot you don't have
much temporal resolution with functional
mri does that make sense
okay
um
okay
the because it's this very indirect
signal that also means that we get it
when we get a change in the mri signal
we don't exactly know what's causing it
is it synaptic activity is it actual
neural firing is it one cell inhibiting
another is it a cell making protein you
know i mean it could be any of these
things right so we don't know and that's
a problem
um and another problem is the number you
get out is just the intensity of the
detection of deoxyhemoglobin
it doesn't translate directly into an
absolute amount of neural activity
the consequence of that is all you can
do is compare two conditions
you can never say there was this exact
amount of metabolic activity right there
you can only say it was more in this
condition than that condition
okay
all right so those are the major caveats
nonetheless we can discover some cool
stuff
okay so let's suppose to get back to
face recognition
you wanted to know is face recognition a
different problem in the brain from
object recognition right
if if it was you might want to write
different code to try to understand it
from the code you're writing writing for
object recognition it's something you'd
kind of want to know okay
so here's an experiment i did god 20
years ago anyway
simplest possible thing so it's an
easiest way i can explain to you the
bare bones of a simple mri experiment
you pop the subject in the scanner
you scan their head continuously for
about five minutes well they look at a
bunch of faces
for 20 seconds they stare at a dot they
look at a bunch of objects they stare at
a dot okay five minute experiment you're
scanning them that whole time
and then you ask of each
three-dimensional pixel or voxel in
their brain
whether the signal was higher in that
voxel while the subject was looking at
faces than while they were looking at
objects
okay and when you do that
you get a blob i've outlined it in green
here but there's a little blob there
this is a slice through the brain like
this that blob is right in here on the
bottom of the brain
and the statistics are telling us that
the mri signal is higher during the face
epochs than the object apex everybody
with me here which implies very
indirectly that the neural activity of
that region was higher when this person
was looking at faces than when they were
looking at objects
okay now whenever you see a blob like
that really you want to see the data
that went into it so here's mine this is
now the raw average mri signal intensity
in that bit of brain over the five
minutes of the scan
you can see the signals higher when that
person is looking at face in that region
when the person is looking at faces
these bars here than when they're
looking at objects there everyone get
that that's what the stats are telling
us this is just the reality check of the
data that produced those stats
okay
so now
in fact you can see something like that
in pretty much every normal person i
could pop any of you in the scanner and
in 10 minutes we'd find yours
okay
um
now here's the key question
does this so far let's suppose you find
this in anyone you do all the stats you
like it's as robust as you could
possibly want
do these data alone tell us that that
region
is specifically responsive to faces
no why
it
not
just like that certain arrangement of um
features or it could be reacting to
the light in terms of
reflecting off
good keep going
what else
yes you could do
yeah then it might still be faces but it
would be different if it's human faces
versus any faces we kind of want to know
right the code would be different yeah
the face is a part of something
absolutely where the object is the whole
thing what else
just objects are simpler or maybe just
easier
maybe it's just hard to distinguish one
face from another and so you need more
blood flow it's just really what that
thing is that's a generic object
recognition system
but it has a harder time distinguishing
faces from each other because they're so
similar so there's more activity
everybody get that
okay what else
i'm going to go two minutes over so if
people have to leave if that's okay i'll
try not to go more than two minutes over
what else
yeah yeah as i just said there's all
this stuff we get from a face not just
who is it but you know are they healthy
what mood are they in are they where
they look and all that stuff
okay so what you guys just did this is
just basic common sense but it's also
the essence of scientific reasoning and
we'll do a lot of that in this class and
the crux of the matter is
here's some data here's an inference and
so your job is to think is there any
other
is there any way that inference might
not follow from those data how else
might we account for those data okay you
guys just did that beautifully okay so
the essence of good science is whenever
you see some data and an inference ask
yourself
how might that inference be wrong how
else might we account for those data
okay so that's what you guys just did i
had previously made a list of other
things that might mean it could respond
to anything human you would said any
kind of face but it could also be just
anything human maybe a response to hands
any body part anything we pay more
attention to
anything that has curves in it or any of
the suggestions you guys made
okay so the crux of the matter and how
you do a good functional mri experiment
or make a strong claim about a part of
the brain based on functional mri is to
take all these alternative accounts
seriously
and so as just one example what we did
in our very first paper is say okay
there's lots of alternative accounts
let's try to tackle a bunch of them so
we scan people looking at now
three-quarter views of faces and hands
and we made them press a button whenever
two consecutive hands were the same
that's called a one-back task or
whenever two consecutive faces are the
same
by design that task is harder on the
hands than the faces so we were forcing
our subjects to pay more attention to
the hands than the faces
okay
and what we found is you get the same
blob still responding more to faces than
hands
and so the idea is by showing that we've
ruled out every one of those things it's
not just any human body part doesn't go
to hands oh so anything human it's not
just any body part it's not anything we
paid attention to because we made them
pay more attention to the hands it's not
anything with curvy outline okay and so
that's just a little you know tiny
example of how you can proceed in a
systematic way
to try to analyze
what is actually driving this region of
the brain you come up with a hypothesis
and then you think of alternatives to
the data and you come up with more
hypotheses and then you think of ways to
test them
and we'll do a lot of that in here
okay that's what i just said um and i'll
just say that there's lots of data since
then that region of the brain is
actually extremely uh very much prefers
faces um and it's present in everyone
and next time we will talk about um uh
the fact that that looks like it's
suggesting that we have a different
system for face recognition for than
object recognition but there's a lot we
haven't yet nailed the case and you guys
should all think about what remains
okay thank you sorry i was racing there
i will hang out if you guys have
questions